rats all we do is take Dad I'm tired but
rats are also useful for aging research
and for cooking Ratatouille but in all
seriousness take a look at this recent
headline article
we have the oldest living female spark
Dolly rats said Dr Harold catcher a
former biology professor at the
University of Maryland now Chief
scientific officer at ufand research a
california-based startup
so Rejuvenation and rats that's what
we're talking about today and how this
rat has apparently become the longest
living rat for a species following
concentrated plasma injections taken
from Young rats and what this could mean
for human Therapeutics along with my
perspectives
but before we get there we must go back
back to the late 1950s and early 1960s
to a time when the Shiki Science Show
didn't even exist but when researchers
such as Clive McKay did and these
researchers were conducting a procedure
called heterochronic parabiosis
simply surgically joining two animals
together such that they share a
circulatory system sounds a bit Grim
it's shocking perhaps even wine
spittingly shocking but it provided an
experimental system to test the systemic
effects on aging and different tissues
since the circulatory system irrigates
the body
the Hatchery here refers to mixed
different whereas chronic care means age
so the lifespan was measured in both
homochronic and heterochronic pairs so
if using old with olds or young with
young or older with young respectively
the early work first suggested it could
beneficially influence the older ads and
that exposure to a young systemic
environment was beneficial
a landmark paper in 2005 by the Convoy
lab confirmed these early results
showing its ameliorated aging phenotypes
but the question remains was the effect
due to the presence of rejuvenating
factors in the young Bloods or was it
due to a dilution effect of pro-aging
factors in the old Bloods
okay so let's rewind further back what
even is in blood full stop
well firstly there's the red blood cells
that carry oxygen around the body and
then we have the white blood cells and
platelets responding to wounds and
infections very important and then we
have the plasma the soluble fraction of
blood that contains water ions proteins
mainly albumin but also some
inflammatory and growth factors
nutrients gases hormones yeah our blood
carries a lot and so you can think of
blood as a transport and communication
Channel
and so in a previous video I covered
follow-up work by the convoys that
proved dilution of pro-aging factors
could be explanation
for the beneficial effects seen in
heterochronic parabiosis here they
performed plasma exchange so this
involved separating out Bloods so that
you spin down and keep the blood cells
but they replace the plasma the parts
containing the proteins with a solution
of physiological saline and albumin and
they found that this replacement alone
was sufficient to get Rejuvenation and
three germ tissue layers
but while it provides evidence that
aging was caused by pro-aging factors
that were eliminated it didn't rule out
the fact that there could have been
anti-aging slash rejuvenating factors in
the young Bloods and I'm just going to
point out now that I'm really not a big
fan of using the dichotomy in terms of
talking about factors in the plasma but
for Simplicity I will stick with them
for now
and that's because there is still
evidence from the sides of these
anti-aging factors a 2014 paper showed
that Youngblood were first age-related
impairments and cognitive function and
synaptic plasticity in mice
so as part of the paper they took just
the young blood plasma and administered
it to age mice and thought it improved
hippocampal dependent learning anyhow
this brings us back to this man here Dr
Harold catcher who I'm coming across
some of this early work on heterochronic
parabiosis in a search for a human
Rejuvenation therapy as he describes in
his book The Illusion of knowledge the
solution became clear
cellular aging did not depend on the
cell's history but on its environments
bodily aging was not the results of
cellular aging rather cellular aging was
caused by bodily aging
and he sought out to further test this
Theory
culture was the supporter of the
presence of their being factors and
young Bloods that have rejuvenating
potential and so he was like you with me
so let's do this thing
but having an idea is just the beginning
he needed to test it and to cause the
long story short which he describes most
of the offense in his book he ended up
working with researchers in Mumbai India
where they began injecting something
called E5 into the telfains of rats The
quick summary is that he wanted to do
heterochronic plasma exchange but
without the expertise equipment to do so
they instead took the plasma from The
Young rats fractionated it and
concentrated it
and they called it E5 e I'm guessing for
Alexa E5 because well is the fifth
letter of the alphabet all because 789
who knows but let's discuss in more
detail what they did in these tests
let's start with the rats
the rats they were using were spark
Dolly rats an outbred breed of albino
rats used extensively in medical
research the main advantage they possess
are their calmness and ease of handling
with a typical lifespan of 2.5 to 3.5
years
and the procedure is as follows the rats
beginning at around two years old were
injected four times with E5 over 8 days
so that's those one and then they had a
second dose given on day 95 and this
figure is summarizing what I just said
and also some of the tests that they did
the rats were either given E5 or saline
infusions as a control
and the results of these tests can be
found mostly in Harold's book but also
on this pre-print article which in case
you don't know what that means it means
it hasn't been through peer review
but it has got the figures in color and
it's free for anyone to access
to just bear that at the back of your
minds so one marker that they examined
in these mice that were treated was grip
strength
this video shows how they did it and
take a close look the first rat was an
untreated old rat while the seconds was
given E5
now you don't want to know how many
times I really watched parts of this
video but it does even by eye seem like
the treated rats are showing more
assistance to the manual pulling by the
Handler but the fully Quantified data
released so far can be seen here
and so it seems like the treated rat had
an improved grip strength but this is
just one measure and catcher continues
to break down on his book other results
collected that's also seen in this
pre-prints other markers they looked at
include the levels of interleukin-6 and
tnf Alpha both protein factors linked
with senescence and inflammation
the orange bar shows the treated old
mice and it shows that decline on
treatments that increases again before
declining again following the second
dose of E5 caterer marks in his book how
following the second dose the inevitable
rise seems to be slower than the
following than following the first dose
which seems compelling
cognition given previous papers the
researchers were interested to see how
cognitive function was altered since the
decline and cognitive function a seam of
age they tested learning a memory with
the Bond's maze test essentially this
involves timing how long it takes for
the rats to escape
so with time the latency declines and
with the young plotted in blue being the
fastest and while it is clear here that
E5 is having an impact on these tests
it's also quite interesting to note the
initial lag of the impact following the
first treatment
this could potentially inform the
molecular offense that must happen in
the brain
but who really knows at this point and
so to go along with these clinical and
molecular biomarkers of Aging they also
looked at DNA methylation
this is used as a proxy for biological
age
as sets of DNA methylation marks are the
interchange with age and so catch a
white with Steve Horvath who pioneered
this field on this step and was able to
develop one of these epigenetic agent
clocks that worked for protecting both
human and rat aging a so-called dual
species clock and it is shown here that
this E5 injection more than half the
epigenetic ages or blood's heart and
liver tissue either had a less
pronounced but statistically significant
Rejuvenation effect observed in the
hypothalamus so region of the brain and
the author's comments that the
Rejuvenation of non-blood organs from
this intravenous treatment coupled with
reversal of the epigenetic clock Within
These organs supports the notion that
aging can be systemically controlled at
least in part through the circulatory
system with plasma as the medium and
it's also worth me mentioning here that
the fact that there is a reduction in
this human rats pan tissue clock
suggests that there is some conservation
of the aging process across the species
and that if it worked with the rats then
potentially there's a good chance this
him could happen for humans but we'll
come back to that at the end in the
discussion
and we could also just disregard this
evidence completely as there is still no
agreement over whether or a reduction in
epigenetic cage is biologically
meaningful but in combination with the
other results are shown it does become
quite compelling which brings us back to
the recent news articles Seema the 47
month old rats almost four years old now
covering the headlines
she is a female rat which is also
interesting because it is mentioned in
the book and Howard is mentioned in
online interviews that they tend to see
a greater Improvement in the male rats
than the females in the grub strength
video I showed earlier they were female
rats but as Katja says it wasn't working
as well
in our initial test you know it was work
we definitely saw a difference
but
my own thinking which may be totally
wrong of course
is that the ovary plays an important
part in language female aging
but again without more data coming out I
can't really say much more indeed the
results from catch's latest study will
only be written when SEMA dies which is
hopefully when we can also find out what
this mysterious E5 plasma actually
consists of as the book also doesn't
give much away and this is partly due to
patents and this also explains why it's
not been published because top journals
can't publish work until they reveal
what E5 is as without knowing what E5 is
other scientists can't repeat the
findings and they clearly want to be
able to commercialize it so yes that's
that and then depending on the source
there will be ethical issues according
to their patent I put the link in the
description they list potential protein
components but there could also be RNA
DNA presence and other metabolites and
to be fair really little is detailed at
the moment for the reasons I just
explained
and while most commonly pigs are
mentioned as the source it also States
here that other mammals such as cows
sheep and even humans
could also be used and so irrespective
there's going to be some other cool
concerns for some people
an alternative
would be to just work out which of the
components in E5 is beneficial and just
deliver those and manifest manufacture
them officially
this could also potentially improve
safety over immune reactions the
apparently he haven't observed any so
far
but that said they do list potential
protein components which includes
complement C3 which I know as part of
the innate immune response so go figure
I don't know
and those of you paying close attention
will have realized I never defined what
I meant by Rejuvenation her but General
loose definition is a procedure that
referses age as opposed to slowing it
down the latter being jury protective
with the limited data so far some of the
graphs suggest that this is a
Rejuvenation procedure but again more of
the data is needed which brings me to my
third point which is how reproducible is
it again without the peer review
publication it's hard to know but Steve
Horvath is quoted to say in this
Guardian article that some people will
criticize the results due to their low
sample size not me one swallow does not
make a summer but I believe the results
because several complementary studies
support them he anticipates safe and
effective treatments will emerge from
the Plasma Research in the next 20 years
and this is backed up by catcher himself
in a recent interview he had this to say
yeah no no I'm I'm pretty sure we'll
within a year or two we'll be able to
extend the lifespan
and a youth and humans I plan to keep
one of the first volunteers
though I would like to definitely see
more numbers tested and to have some
clarity over how standardized this E5
treatment is and more functional tests
but given the systemic nature of the
circulatory system and the other studies
I mentioned at the start of the video
along with this being a minimally
invasive procedure for sure makes this a
feasible treatment strategy I feel like
so far as his book title suggests
culture has given us the illusion of
knowledge that this procedure is working
but I'm sure all will become very clear
when the data comes out
when it's gone through peer review
all we have to do for now is see how
long SEMA lives wait for the paper to
come out to show what E5 is and to watch
this video here and as a quick plug as
well
um I will be presenting at this upcoming
curing aging conference and I'll put a
link to it below
with that thank you to my patreon
supporters and catch you later